jean-marc quels sont les facteurs qui
permettent aux économistes de l' ocde
d'être optimiste sur la capacité sur la
capacité de rebond de l'économie
mondiale
oui alors les prévisions de qui vient de
sortir de l' ocde
hier soir son surpal foriic c'est vrai
que les économistes de l' ocde pensons
encore que ce quatrième trimestre ne
sera très négatif est que nous allons
devoir vivre des mois difficiles
notamment au début de l'année 2000 21
notamment vous le disiez en europe
cela lui et c'est la première fois
depuis le début de cette crise que l'
ocde prévoit une reprise en 2020
l'organisation retient donc un scénario
positif un scénario optimiste au début
de l'année prochaine si le cd eux
pensent même que l'économie mondiale va
récupérer son activité d'avant le coc
vide c'est-à-dire dès la fin de l'année
prochaine dès le mois de décembre 2021
ocde s'appuie pour cela sur quatre
facteurs très rapidement un les
gouvernements et les banques centrales
ont mis le paquet pour soutenir le
système économique se sait ce que
d'ailleurs disait christian de boissieu
ya un instant
c'est vrai en europe mais c'est vrai
aussi aux états unis sous une autre
forme notamment par le biais de la
banque centrale qui a fait le job là bas
aux états unis 2 il existe une épargne
colossale dans le monde entier notamment
chez les particuliers notamment en
france en europe partout en europe
dans beaucoup d'entreprises également
parce que lehman a les managers n'ont
pas connu mais la fin est à consommer ça
vaut cette période il ya donc des
réserves qui peuvent être acquis peuvent
à alimenter des systèmes de production
et puis la chine est repartie très
fortement et les est faible consommation
interne à la chine est bien soutiennent
la reprise mondiale j'ajoute une
quatrième raison mais on en parle
beaucoup de ce sont les vaccins ou
plutôt la vaccination qui se prépare
jamais dans l'histoire des laboratoires
de recherche
nettali as aussi vite des vaccins vont
lever une hypothèque très lourde et
restaurer la confiance c'est de la
confiance dont nous avons peu de toi
oui mais voilà le cda et mais une vraie
berne sur l'europe occidentale mais oui
alors ça c'est très sérieux absolument
l'europe et la partie du monde qui a le
plus sévèrement confiné son activité il
ya donc le plus sévèrement
j'allais dire un peu asphyxié étouffé
son économie l'arrêt brutal dans les
pays de l'union européenne qui n'était
pas en très grande forme déjà avant à
casser complètement l'activité est mis à
jour la nécessité de réformes
structurelles importantes
il va falloir gérer toutes ces familles
et il va falloir gérer le chômage et
investir massivement dans la relance on
le voit bien les plans sociaux se
multiplient
on le voit bien que ces plans sociaux
finalement sont sur des secteurs qui
étaient déjà en mutation auparavant
c'est la raison pour laquelle ocde
recommande au gouvernement de ne pas
relâcher la politique budgétaire il faut
continuer à alimenter des économies avec
des liquidités l'oscd eux ajoute qu'il
faut aussi continuer d'emprunter les
taux d'intérêt sont proches de zéro il
faut donc en profiter et on trouvera
toujours des solutions politiques pour
gérer l'endettement alors ça c'est un
peu moins sûr mais on reporte l'échéance
à l'année prochaine en amérique du nord
et du sud vont repartir plus vite
pourquoi pas parce que les confinements
là bas n'ont pas été très sévère les
dégâts humains en revanche sont beaucoup
plus graves notamment en amérique du sud
notamment aux états unis
l'europe a choisi on le sait bien de
protéger les vies humaines plutôt que
les activités économiques
ça va coûter cher mais c'est un choix
politique et ce qui est spectaculaire
jean-marc c'est le dynamisme des marchés
financiers et des bourses
alors bon c'est spectaculaire c'est à
dire que les bourses n'ont pas craqué
pendant toute cette période de crise
depuis plus d'un an les bourses n'ont
pas craqué nous sommes actuellement à
peu près au niveau du début de la crise
et même légèrement ménages légèrement au
dessus alors c'est intéressant ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'elle financier
finalement et les épargnants n'ont
jamais cru à un effondrement global du
système économique qui n'ont jamais cru
que c'était équivalent à la guerre où
c'était un tremblement de terre ou à la
fin du monde
ils ont considéré que les politiques
avaient fait le job
ils ont pu préserver les potentiels
industriels il n'y a pas eu de
bombardement il n'y a pas eu destruction
d'usinés on a simplement mis à l'arrêt
les appareils de production les avions
sont restés collés au sol les camions
sont restés dans l'est dans les parkings
il suffirait donc que la confiance
revienne pour que tout ça redémarre et
la confiance et bien elle dépend d'un
seul facteur
elle dépend de la vaccination merci jean
marc sylvestre pour ce décryptage
complet